[Music]
in I can do better news submitted by
maybe my first daughter Julio oh I just
a disgruntled 7/11 owner opened a
competing six of six twelve visits right
across but that's some Chinese [ __ ]
right that what is slow like that's
interesting that he went one down and
one up as opposed to like both going
want to open earlier and later even in
tow 36:10 because the phrases you know
people do like 24/7 and they go I did I
should twenty five eight and you get it
no one says 23 eight yeah it's like what
the hell are you sleeping one hour it's
like we keep it moderate one seven
eleven called seven eleven because it
was open from seven to 11 is 11 hours
because now they lie it's 24/7 hmm I
don't know no seven eleven that's not
open 24/7 so funny numbers some of them
some of them weren't there's one uh and
I think like Buena Park was it and then
we would try to get some snacks at 2:00
a.m. after being like how long really
late in uh in high school oh yeah
sometimes when the Slurpee machine is
broken I get [ __ ] mad even yeah all
the [ __ ] wit yeah till this day I'm
talking recently because it's not often
that I get to have a coke float and when
I finally can do it I pull up and I walk
in and it's like oh the machines just
[ __ ] circling and circling in the red
light is on it's like I feel that we
have the movie theater - I think it's
funny well I understand your situation
but your situations hilarious to me
because in relation to where the offices
7-eleven you can literally walk there in
five minutes you can walk so and he
never walks he drives so he's there in
thirty second chair walk their apartment
is obsessed fall and he gets his I don't
get that far I get pissed at the movie
theater though that's different you went
in with a certain expectation Oh what is
his expectation was just to get with
just yet his cosign but I want to
include the fact that he traveled so
there was like a whole like plan
I did travel schedule he needed to do a
bunch of stuff but this one I've got a
bottle my chair that's [ __ ] traveling
now it's like I go there and I'm like
[ __ ] man I wanted the coke flow now I
have to get cherry or something else and
I'm like dude cool problem and you
should always drive to a different 7/11
that's asking way too much Julia Basel I
didn't even pop it my head are from each
other yeah are they yeah wish there's
not like McDonald necklace almost like
everyone yeah you have to drive next to
the ten what's the next time 111 off the
top your head three two one now
telephone one next to the mama I have to
700 11 via the place that I live and
they're like with an equal visit so much
the coke machines aren't working oh my
god hated that would be terrible right
yeah so this this man is name is Abu
cosmology so he was a franchise owner
and he said that like he had a lot of
conflicting issues with 7/11 because
like for example one of the reasons was
that he wanted to stop serving hot foods
at his store because he kept wasting
like two to three hundred dollars worth
of food every single day it's a waste of
money nobody buys it
nobody buys and so 7-eleven didn't let
him like they're like another peddle
this [ __ ] has to though so then like
that's when you know they had other
disagreement and got down to the point
where he the company attempted to revoke
his franchise but then eventually both
sides ended up left fella they reached
the settlement for an undisclosed amount
of money and so then that was a few
years ago so and now he's opened up a
six-mile right across the street from
his 7-eleven well you crossed out the
one that he owned before it'd been
better he has actual like a fixed what
looks like a sharpie marker over it I
would let him right yeah like similar
similar design but way different colors
7-eleven like orange and green or
something and green and void
yeah but if it was like still the white
and then now it's like turquoise and
red or something it gets close enough oh
no no what you're trying to do but it's
just on the other side of lava they
can't reach you
lunch is do this as I do that they're
having I use the same like I saw
someplace had was using the GameStop
font for they're like chicken store like
game there's that doctor's office that
use the Calvin Klein font your people
awesome
maybe maybe he wanted to stay extra safe
I think so 11 of course is what it looks
like so this is like he's open six days
a week 12 hours a day
I'm not even 24 hours over 24 hours but
I do not know he said that he meant he
knows every single item that's being
sold into 7-eleven so he purposefully
makes his items slightly cheaper than 11
so his goal is to get that 7-eleven
close you know what's [ __ ] up is
because he probably sold that franchise
to someone else so someone else is
buying into this thing thinking first
time business owner I'm going to try it
and your [ __ ] business goes to [ __ ]
because the previous owner runs you out
of the business I had a sense walked on
like what about the new person 7-eleven
in the gift [ __ ] they don't care the
business owner that I get that gospel
yeah all if it's if the corporate took
over and bottomed out then it makes
sense why is his lips the same colors is
scary I don't know yeah but this is a
Bruin so he's saying that more than half
of his because it looks like an Indian
version of my cousin oh yeah I could do
that as a boo thing that more than half
of his customers from the 7-eleven when
he owned it as now is now going to 612 I
support him because a lot of the
customers are saying well yeah it's like
you know it's like the American success
story like you know going against court
the corporation and it's like it's
because he's complaining the whole time
every time as a customer can you believe
that I've heard that all this warm food
I'm doing it the way it is probably
doing that every single day but he has a
personal connection with his customers
which is dope because you know aunt
owned a liquor store and he was telling
me that a lot of it is customer service
because you know all liquor stores have
the same [ __ ] they got the same kind of
and these same kind of juices same kind
of alcohol same kind of tobacco same
Arnold magazines so what exactly but
what what separates you from the other
store is your friendliness customer
service that's a very tender hot latino
poster girls all around the store the
corona girls always they make it sound
like this dude was down and out in his
log and he like strived really hard to
do it like I think little do they know
that it takes a lot of money for you to
franchise at 7-eleven this guy was
already doing very well and it was just
a matter of differences this guy's
really petty to be honest who a bully
yeah really [ __ ] petty this is like he
sold focused on the negative [ __ ] that I
wouldn't be surprised if you should do
okay so he has to throw away the warm
food out and as a hundred dollars worth
of food every day
yeah and 911 isn't giving him money to
pay for that food he's coming out of his
own pocket
he's like look here's the counting I'm
wasting 300 bucks a month
mmm it don't make hunting Oh a day 300
bucks a day that's a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ]
money now it just gotta like wiring up
10 grand a month
yeah 300 bucks a day I will be petty too
hard [ __ ] pissed because yeah why
because that's all franchises for I know
but I don't care how they work I still
be paying nine grand a month
yeah so it's right for him to say [ __ ]
it ah they I can't go with their rules
whatever I'm gonna do my own [ __ ] but
it's Teddy when you have to do right
across the street call it 612 also
what's the non petty way to do it then
just open up your own business somewhere
else and call it something else but what
if you always customer base is there
yeah because it's all about customer
service fine that's fine leave it there
across the street but call it [ __ ] up
who's [ __ ] pelas
you don't I mean I thought that I
thought the penny part was it was like
the competing business though because
he's like undercutting his old business
also that's I mean that was clear he's
got to compete so like I agree but I
don't agree at the same time I know he's
[ __ ] I see it as he took his time to
build his customer base and if that's
that's your [ __ ] 7-eleven doesn't care
about
that you care about the people so I'm
going to open up in the same
neighborhood that I spent years building
this customer they said I wish you were
to hit me up if I brainstorm with them I
would have called it a booze Bottega so
half of it would be like the normal
snacks you get at 7-eleven then there's
like Indian snack section and then he
also has like Indian takeout but what if
you can't even cook India who you just
being straight right yeah Bobby has
great samosas who said he gotta cook it
for you baby oh my gosh Indian food on a
Slurpee like curry Slurpee no coke
Slurpee with it Indian food
Turkey that'd be delicious run mango
lassi and a [ __ ] side because frequent
that [ __ ] angle lossy frozen yogurt yup
so you should have brainstorm with me
because I came up with something
together hey you guys want to stock any
of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]
[Music]